WE HAVE A AUTHOR HERE SENATOR
MORLOCK WHO'S ALWAYS.
ON TIME AND I APPRECIATE HIS
TIME VALUES SO -- SOONER MORE
OCTAVE YOU'RE READY WE'LL START
WHICH ARE YOUR SP FOUR NINE SIX
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I SWATCH.
COLLEAGUES IN JANUARY.
IT WAS ANNOUNCED THAT A RECORD
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR SUSPECTED
CASES.
OF ELDER FINANCIAL ABUSE
REPORTED TO THE TREASURY
DEPARTMENT LAST YEAR.
THIS IS MORE THAN DOUBLE THE
AMOUNT FIVE YEARS EARLIER
ACCORDING TO GOVERNMENT DATA
[inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
THE GROWING ELDERLY POPULATION
CALIFORNIA NEEDS AN ASSISTANT
PROTECTING ITS SENIORS.
BANKS ARE ALREADY MANDATED
REPORTERS BROKER DEALERS AND
INVESTMENT ADVISERS SHOULD
PARTICIPATE AS WELL.
THIS IS THE PURPOSE OF SENATE
BILL. FOR NINETY SIX FOR NINETY
SIX IMPLEMENTS THE NORTH
AMERICAN SECURITIES
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION'S
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH HAS
ALREADY BEEN ADOPTED IN SOME
FORM BY NINETEEN STATES.
I APPRECIATE THE REVIEW OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
YEAH THIS IS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE.
I BELIEVE WE DO SEEING NONE
COMING FAR THAT WE HAVE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
CENA NAINA -- YOU GET A TWEENER
SEE GUESTS AND TO ENTER SORRY
ALL RIGHT OKAY.
YES YOU MAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO INVEST IN
COURT REPRESENTING THE
SECURITIES INDUSTRY.
AND FINANCIAL MARKETS
ASSOCIATION ALSO KNOWN AS THE
FLAT.
WE HAVE A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL -- IF I MAY
MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE TO TAKE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO THANK SENATOR
MORE LIKE HIS STAFF AND YOUR AND
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT. FOR ALL
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL.
I DON'T WANT TO REPEAT ANYTHING
THAT SENATOR MORE LIKE HE SAID I
THINK WE JUST CAN SAY THAT WE
AGREE -- THE SECURITIES
INDUSTRY'S WILLINGLY COMING TO
THE TABLE TO SAY YES WE WANT TO
BE MANDATED REPORTERS.
BECAUSE WE THINK IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO -- SYSTEM HAS WORKED
ON OVER TWENTY REPORT AND HOLD
PROPOSALS WITH STATE LEGISLATORS --
FEDERAL AND STATE REGULATORS AND
WE'RE BEING VERY PROACTIVE NOT
REACTIVE.
I LIKE TO TAKE TIME TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS REGARDING
OUR PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
IT'S NOT OUR INTENT TO HOLD UP
THE BILL OR CAUSE ANY TYPE OF
OPPOSITION OUR INTENT IS ALWAYS
BEEN TO INCREASE INVESTOR
PROTECTION.
AN EFFORT TO MOVE FORWARD -- BUT
WITH ONE EXCEPTION WOULD LIKE TO
WITHDRAW THEIR REQUEST FOR
AMENDMENTS.
THE ONE EXCEPTION IS VERY
IMPORTANT THOUGH.
ON PAGE TEN LINES SIX THROUGH.
TWELVE IT DEALS WITH THE
MANDATED REPORTERS NOTIFICATIONS
VIA A TRUSTED CONTACT PERSON.
THE COMMUTE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
RIGHTLY POINTS OUT.
THIS STANDARD IS THAT THIS IS A
STANDARD PRACTICE IN THE
SECURITIES INDUSTRY.
WHICH IS ALSO CONSISTENT WITH
THE RULES OF THE FINANCIAL
INDUSTRY REGULATORY AUTHORITY
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS SPINNERETS.
WELL THIS IS TRUE.
AS DRAFTED SENATE BILL FOR
NINETY SIX ONLY ADDRESSES
REACHING OUT FOR FINANCIAL
EXPLOITATION.
IT MAY BE INTERPRETED AS
LIMITING THE OTHER INSTANCES IN
WHICH IS A FAVORITE TRUSTED
CONTACT CAN BE USED.
OUR PROPOSED AMENDMENT WOULD
ALSO CLEAR FIGHT THAT WE CAN
COMPLY WITH SPECIFIC OBLIGATIONS
UNDER GRAMM LEACH BLILEY AND THE
SECURITIES AND EXCHANGE
COMMISSION REGULATIONS.
I'M SURE THIS IS NOT THE INTENT
OF THE SENATOR IT DOES NEED TO
BE CLARIFIED.
MY HOPE AND AND I HOPE I THINK
WE WILL GET THERE THAT WE CAN
SUPPORT THE BILL -- AND WITH
THAT I THINK.
YOU ANY OTHER TRAINERS THERE.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
IS THERE ANY QUESTIONS SENATOR
CAFIERO.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
HERE THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
AREA -- AS WE HAVE A AGING
POPULATION WE'RE GONNA NEED MORE
OVERSIGHT TO HELP -- TO MANAGE.
THEIR MONEY IN A WAY AND TO HAVE
MANDATORY REPORTERS I THINK IS
REALLY GREAT THE CONCERN I HAD
WAS -- WAS IN IN IN TERMS OF A
BOMB.
AND AND THE REPORT THE REPORT
BEING MADE ON THAT THERE THERE
MAY BE AN IRREGULARITY AND
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THEIR MAYBE ABUSE -- GOING ON
THAT THE ELDER THE DEPENDED
DON'T MAY NOT HAVE ANY RCOURSE
AFTER DELAYED THE TRANSACTION IS
MADE THEY WOULD HAVE TO LET THE
PROCESS.
PLAY ITSELF OUT WHICH MEANS IT
THEY MAY HAVE TO WAIT FIFTEEN
DAYS AND I'M JUST CONCERNED
ABOUT -- AT SITUATIONS WHERE
THERE IS NO ABUSE AND THE AND
THE INDIVIDUAL IS IS GOT.
SOMETHING THEY'RE GOING TO USE
THE MONEY FOR AN CAN CAN USE AND
I WAS WONDERING IF YOU HAD -- IT
IT LOOKS TO ME LIKE -- AND
DETERMINATION BY THE MANDATED
REPORTED THAT THE TRANSACTION.
WILL NOT RESULT IN FINANCIAL
ABUSE MAY TAKE THE THAT FIFTEEN
DAYS AND SO WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
MEANTIME.
IS THERE ANY WAY TO KIND OF
OVERCOME THAT -- POSITIVELY BY
THE THE ELDER THAT'S BEING --
REPORTED ON OR THE MONEY THEIR
MONEY'S BEING REPORTED ON THAT'S
A GREAT QUESTION CENTER CAN BE
OUR OWN I DON'T HAVE A PRECISE
ANSWER OTHER THAN -- IN CERTAIN
INSTANCES -- ELDERLY INDIVIDUALS
WILL HAVE -- RECOGNIZED.
ADULT CHILDREN THAT ARE A
PARTICIPATING YOU THROUGH A PART
OF ATTORNEY -- CONSERVATORSHIP
OR SOME OTHER FORM OF
GUARDIANSHIP -- AND IN IDEA BUT
I I WOULD THINK THAT YOU WOULD
CONTACT THEM. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE TRANSACTION IS IS LEGITIMATE.
OR TRYING TO PREVENT.
INSTANCES WERE EARLY SIGNS OF
DEMENTIA THEY START.
DOING ALL CANCER UNIQUE THINGS
AND AND SO -- WE WILL THE THE
THE PUSH BACK WE'VE GOTTEN IS
THAT MAYBE FIFTEEN DAYS IS TOO
SHORT.
SO -- BUT I CAN GET BACK TO ON A
MORE PRECISE ANTHROPOLOGY YOU
KNOW IT AND THAT IT'S FINE I
JUST WANTED TO KIND OF RAISE IT
IS A RED FLAG.
HAVING GONE THROUGH THIS -- THIS
EXACT SCENARIO THAT YOU TALK
ABOUT WHERE ON OF THE THE
INDIVIDUAL MY MY FATHER WHO WAS
IN CHARGE OF FINE THE FINANCES --
STARTED MAKING DECISIONS IT
DIDN'T LOOK IN THE BEST
INTERESTS WE WERE ABLE TO CATCH
THAT -- AS WE WERE LOOKING
THROUGH THE BANK.
STATEMENTS.
AND BUT BUT IS AB.
THERE MAY NOT BE SOME ADULT
CHILDREN THAT ARE THAT ARE
WATCHING AND THERE MAY NOT BE.
THAT KIND OF OVERSIGHT FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME AND I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
TAKING THE RIGHT AWAY FROM THE
THE ELDERLY INDIVIDUAL TO MAKE
THEIR OWN CHOICES AND AND AND
AND SO MAYBE.
AN ADVISEMENT WITH THE BACKSTOP
OF OF OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS
COMING IN YOU CAN YOU CAN NARROW
THE TIME I JUST IT'S A SINCE I
DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING IN HERE.
I JUST THOUGHT WE MAY WANT TO
THINK ABOUT IT A LITTLE BIT --
WE ENDED UP IN SOME VERY ODD
INSTANCES.
WHERE WE COULDN'T LOOK AT THINGS --
EXPEDITIOUSLY BECAUSE I HAD A
ONCE MY FATHER PASSED I HAD TO
TAKE MY MOTHER DOWN WHO HAS
ALZHEIMER'S.
AND STAND IN LINE FOR HOURS TO
GET THINGS DONE AT THE BANK AND
IT WAS THE MOST RIDICULOUS SET
OF CIRCUMSTANCES EVEN THOUGH I
HAD THE POWER OF ATTORNEY I HAD
THE TRUST.
DOCUMENTS ALL THAT KIND OF STUFF.
IF WE PUT TOO MANY OBSTACLES ON
THE BANKS AND IN THE END THEIR
ATTORNEYS WILL SAY NO YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO GET A COURT ORDER
WHICH I WAS NOT WILLING.
TO TO WHEN I HAD ALL THE
PAPERWORK SO I I'M VERY
SENSITIVE TO THIS KIND OF THING
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO I THINK IT'S
THE RIGHT THING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF I IF I
MAY.
UM.
DURING THAT TIME THERE IS AN OF
ITS INVESTIGATION GOING ON AND
WHAT BY THIS BILLS ALSO SUPPORT
BECAUSE IT TALKS ABOUT.
WHO CAN BE CONTACTED?
I KNOW WHAT TYPE OF CIRCUMSTANCE
TWO SO I THINK IT'S AT THE
CLARIFICATION THAT.
NEEDS TO BE MADE.
I WANT TO STOP IS A QUORUM SHOW
WE HAVE.
GROWN HERE SO MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE [inaudible]
CHIANG.
CARILLO YOUR COMMANDER HERE
DRAWS -- DRESSER HERE WES SO.
WELL.
PORTANTINO.
MMHM IS PRESENT.
ARM I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR OF
THIS MEASURE IT'S ONE OF GREAT
IMPORTANCE ARE AND I APPRECIATE
YOU WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
TO IRON OUT SOME THOSE
CHALLENGES AND ALSO -- ADDRESSED
THE CONCERNS THAT WERE MENTIONED --
BY THE TWEENER HERE SO -- ALSO.
LIKES -- I I HAVE A PERSONAL
FRIEND WHO'S GOING TO SOME
ISSUES RIGHT NOW WITH THEIR
SENIOR MOTHER AND HAVING
ACCOUNTS CLOSED BECAUSE OF THE
SUSPICIOUS ACTIVITY SO.
IS GREATLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
LOOK AFTER OUR MOST PRECIOUS
RESOURCE AND THAT'S OUR AARON
CHEN ARE.
ELDERLY FOLKS WHO HAVE COME
BEFORE SO -- ON THAT NOTE TO
LEARN MORE LOG SELECT CLOSE
MATURE I DID AVOID PERSONAL.
STORIES ANECDOTAL STORIES
BECAUSE THEY ARE.
THEY'RE TOUGH AND SO -- ALL
WE'RE SAYING IS.
WE GOT TO WORK TOGETHER AS A
TEAM BECAUSE THERE'S SEVEN
THINGS ARE SO SUBTLE YOU DON'T
SEE IT HAPPENING WHEN IT'S
HAPPENING AND THEN WHEN YOU
FINALLY REALIZE WHAT'S GOING ON
IT'S IT COULD BE TOO LATE AND SO.
THIS IS A TOOL TO HELP.
ADVISERS THAT ARE WORKING WITH A
SOPHISTICATED PEOPLE THAT.
THINGS COULD CHANGE FIVE
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I BOTH
THANK YOU.
YOU WILL BE TAKING AMENDMENTS
AND JUDICIARY AND MY CORRECT
CORRECT AND CARE.
SO WE DO HAVE A TO PASS OUR
RECOMMENDATION WITH A MEMBER TO
BE TAKEN IN JUDICIARY -- COME
GET MOTIONS BILL.
IT'S BEEN MOVED.
THEM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN INTO TO
SHERRY SENATOR BRADFORD AYE
BRADFORD AYE CHIANG.
CHING I HAVE A YELLOW.
THE BATTLE AYE DURAZO.
DRESSER I WAS SO.
I BROWN [inaudible]
YOU KNOW [inaudible] FIVE THAT
MEASURES OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLL
OPEN FOR THOSE ABSENT MEMBERS TO
HE ADDED ON THANK YOU -- NEXT UP
WE WANT WE TAKE OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE -- TWO ITEMS ON
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SHOW WE CAN GET A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT.
AND SO MOVED -- AND WILL CALL
ROLE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
I'M SORRY WE HAVE SB -- TWO FIVE
ONE WHICH S COMMITTEE AND
BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS -- COMMITTEE BILL
AND WE HAVE SB FOUR FIVE FIVE
WHICH IS SYMBOLIC OF AYE GAINING
BRADFORD SO -- WE DO PASS.
A YAHOO.
SENATOR BRADFORD AYE BRADFORD HI
CHENG CHIANG I HAVE A YELLOW.
I DRUGS SO.
DRUGS SO I WEST SO.
SO I BROWN.
OUR CALENDARS HOW IT WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
TO BE ADDED ON IT NEXT WE HAVE
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB FOUR SEVEN
TWO BY SENATOR CAPPIELLO WHEN
YOU'RE READY
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND SENATORS -- THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY PRINT PRESENT SB.
FOUR SEVENTY TWO WHICH PROVIDES
STATUTORY CLARITY FOR REGULATING
EARNED INCOME ACCESS PROGRAMS.
EARNED INCOME ACCESS PROGRAMS
ALLOW CONSUMERS TO ACCESS A
PORTION OF THE WAGES THEY HAVE
ALREADY EARNED PRIOR TO THEIR
SCHEDULED PAYDAY -- IS HOW A
SIMPLE PROGRAM WORKS A CONSUMER
REQUIRES IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO HIS
OR HER MONEY.
USING AN APP THE CONSUMER CAN
QUICKLY ACCESS UP TO HALF OF THE
AMOUNT OF HIS OR HER EARNED
UNPAID INCOME DURING A GIVEN PAY
PERIOD. FOR THE ENTIRE PAY
PERIOD OR FOR A SINGLE FIXED FEE.
THIS IS THIS BE IS A
NONRECURRING FEE AND ONLY PAID
IF AND WHEN A CONSUMER CHOOSES
TO USE THE PROGRAM.
AND THE FEE IS LESS THAN A
TYPICAL BANK OVERDRAFT FEE FOR A
LATE FEE.
WITH THE FOR A FEW SCREEN TAP
USERS CAN HAVE INSTANT ACCESS TO
THEIR ALREADY EARNED UNPAID
WAGES.
WHETHER IT'S TO COVER AN
UNEXPECTED COST FOR JUST AVOID A
LATE OR OVERDRAFT FEE SOMETIMES
PEOPLE JUST NEED A LITTLE EXTRA
MONEY.
IN FACT 70% OF THE HOUSEHOLDS
LIVE PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK EVEN
PEOPLE OF MEANS AND THESE
FINANCE CHARGES INTEREST
PAYMENTS CHECK CASHING FEES LATE
FEES ON MONTHLY BILLS AND OTHER
EXPENSES.
CAN OFTEN RAN AS MUCH AS TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY THIS
FINANCIAL TAX IS A HIGHLY
REGRESSIVE TAX IMPOSED ON THOSE
WHO ARE OFTEN OFTEN LEAST ABLE
TO PAY.
BY CREATING A STATUTORY
FRAMEWORK FOR EARNED INCOME
ACCESS PROGRAMS WE CAN PROVIDE A
SAFE WAY FOR CUSTOMERS TO GET
THEIR MONEY WHEN THEY NEED IT.
IT IS A TOOL FOR PEOPLE TO USE
THAT COMES WITH GUARDRAILS
PROTECTIONS AND FLEXIBILITY.
THE PROTECTIONS IN SB FOUR
SEVENTY TO ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS
ARE HELD HARMLESS AND SINCE IT'S
NOT ALONE THEY CAN'T DEFAULT.
I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT I HAVE
BEEN IN CONTACT WITH CONSUMER
GROUPS AND LOOK FOR FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR DISCUSSIONS ON
HOW TO BUILD SOLID PARAMETERS
AROUND THESE EARNED INCOME
ACCESS PROGRAMS.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL AND I'M
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS
DAN QUAN WHO MOSTRI RECENTLY
SERVED IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AS SENIOR ADVISER.
TO DIRECTOR RICHARD CORDRAY AT
THE CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION BUREAU MY COMP ID.
CARPENTER ON BEHALF OF ACTIVE
AND YOU JUDGE ON MORE ACTIVE CEO
WHO CAN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW THE PROGRAM WOULD WORK.
HAS BEEN MOVING IN ON ALL THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO TESTIFY
SHOWN IN WHAT ORDER JERSEY.
SCORE YOU GOING FOR SURE MISTER
CHAIRMAN MY CARPENTER ON BEHALF
OF THE ACTIVE.
MORE VERY ENTHUSED TO SPONSOR
THE BILL VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
THE THE DEMONSTRATE THE BENEFITS
OF EARNED WAGE ACCESS PROGRAMS
TO CONSUMERS.
EARN WAGES ACCESS IS A SOCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE CONSUMER DRIVEN
INNOVATIVE NEW PROGRAM THAT
SIMPLY ALLOWS WORKERS TO ACCESS
A PORTION OF THE WAGES.
THEY'VE ALREADY EARNED.
I ALSO WANTED TO THANK.
THE AUTHOR THE AUTHOR STAFF OF
THE VERY DILIGENT -- COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT WHO'S WORKED ON THIS
AS WELL AS THE CONSUMER AND
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS WHO WE'VE --
NOT REACHING OUT TO AS WE WORK
TOGETHER TO DEVELOP A VERY
STRONG STATUTORY FRAMEWORK FOR
THESE PROGRAMS.
WE'RE HERE BECAUSE AS THE
ANALYSIS DOES A NICE JOB OF
POINTING OUT.
EARNED WAGE ACCESS PROGRAMS
DON'T FIT INTO ANY CURRENT
REGULATORY CONSTRUCT -- OUR
CLIENT MET WITH ACT WAS MET WITH
THE D. BO AND THEY URGED US TO
COME TO YOU THE LEGISLATURE FOR
SOME STATUTORY.
CLARITY AND WE THINK THIS
LEGISLATION DOES JUST THAT.
IT ESTABLISHES THE STATUTORY
FRAMEWORK -- THAT THAT WERE
SEEKING.
IT -- PROVIDES STRONG CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS IT IMPOSES A
CONSUMER FRIENDLY AND MEANINGFUL
REQUIREMENTS ON PROVIDERS OF
EARNED WAGE ACCESS.
SO THAT THESE PROGRAMS CAN
REMAIN A FLOURISHING OPTION FOR
CONSUMERS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT KERN
WAGE ACCESS PROVIDES A FOR FAR
LESS EXPENSIVE AND RISKY OPTION
FOR CONSUMERS WHO WANT TO BETTER
MANAGE THEIR CASH FLOW.
AND THEIR FINANCES AND SO WITH
THAT I WOULD -- ASK OUR OUR
EXPERT MISTER QUAN.
TAKE IT FROM HERE.
REMEMBER FOR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY.
SUPPORT OF THIS VERY IMPORTANT
CONSUMER PROTECTION LEGISLATION.
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK CENTER
CUBBY ORAL FOR COMMITMENT AGAIN.
TO CONSUMERS BY INTRODUCING SB.
FOUR SEVENTY TWO THIS
LEGISLATION PROVIDES A NEED IT.
AND OVERDUE STATUTORY FRAMEWORK
FOR THE NEW FUNDING FOR SERVICE
OF WHICH ACCESS PROGRAMS.
BY CREATING STRONG CLEAR
CUSTOMER PROTECTIONS AND IMPOSES
CONSUMER FRIENDLY REQUIREMENTS
I'M PROVIDERS OF WHICH ACCESS
PROGRAMS. TO ENSURE THAT
CONSUMERS CAN ENJOY THE
TREMENDOUS BENEFITS OF THIS
INNOVATIVE AFFORDABLE SAFE
ALTERNATIVE.
MY NAME IS DAN CALL I'M
CURRENTLY A CONSULTANT TO
DESTRUCTIVE EARLY STAGE
COMPANIES INCLUDING PAY ACTIVE.
FOR COME TO THIS BECAUSE I MOST
RECENTLY SERVED IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
AS SENIOR ADVISER TO DIRECTOR
RICHARD CORDRAY OF THE CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION BUREAU CFPB.
IN THAT CAPACITY.
I LET THE CITY'S A THINK TANK
OFFICE WHOSE MISSION WAS TO
PROMOTE CONSUMER FROM THE
INNOVATION.
WHEN I ASSUME THE LEADERSHIP
ROLE IN THE OFFICE IN?
TWENTY THIRTEEN I LASER FOCUSED
ALL IDENTIFYING AND FACILITATING
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES AND
BUSINESS MODELS BUT CAN DISRUPT
SHORT TERM HI CALLS CREDIT
PRODUCTS SUCH AS PRETTY LOANS
AND THE BANK OVERDRAFTS -- WAGE
ACCESS OR D. W. A IS IT
DESTRUCTIVE MODEL THE HELP
CONSUMERS ESPECIALLY LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME CONSUMERS OR THE
MOST FINANCIALLY FRAGILE.
AND THE MOST PROBLEM TOOL FOR
VICTIMS TO PREDATORY AND ABUSE
OF LENDING.
THESE CONSUMERS NEED BETTER
OPTIONS EW ES SIMPLY PROVIDES
CONSUMERS WITH ACCESS TO PART OF
THEIR OWN ALREADY EARNED THE
MONEY AT A SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER
COST THE OTHER OPTIONS.
AND DOESN'T CREATE A THE IN HERE
IN THE RISKS POSED BY A LOAN OR
DEBIT.
OR DEBT OBLIGATION.
ANY OF THE CITY BE WERE
INITIALLY VERY SKEPTICAL OF THE
EASE UP A ONES.
THINKING THEY MIGHT BE NO
DIFFERENT THAN OTHER EXPENSE.
SHORT TERM LENDING -- PRODUCTS.
HOWEVER AFTER A VERY THOUGHTFUL
AND THE CRITICAL EXAMINATION.
THE DEDICATED STAFF AT THE CITY
BE RECOGNIZE THAT YOU DON'T
REALLY PROGRAMS PROVIDE A SAFE
AND A CHEAPER ALTERNATIVE TO
SHORT TERM LOANS FOR CONSUMERS
AND THEREFORE.
THEY WERE TRYING THEIR BEST TO
ENCOURAGE THEM AS A RESULT THE
FINAL A BOMB ON INSPIRATION PAY
THE RLE RELEASED BY THE CFPB IN
LATE.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN CREATED A
SPECIFIC EXEMPTIONS OR RECALL
SAFE HARBORS. TO ACCOMMODATE
RESPONSIBLE EW ES MODELS IN
ORDER TO PROMOTE CONSUMER ACCESS
TO THEM.
THOSE EXEMPTIONS REQUIRE EW ES
PROGRAMS TO INCLUDE MEANINGFUL
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS ARE REELS
IF YOU WELL.
SURE THE PROGRAM IS NOT
PREDATORY.
I HAVE ALSO WORKED EXTENSIVELY
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF TO ADDRESS
THE SAME ISSUE AND SENATOR
CABALLERO HAS INTRODUCED.
AS INCORPORATED ALL THOSE MOST
GHARIALS IN HER BILL.
ALTHOUGH MUCH OF THE PAY THE
RULE IS NOW BEING RESCINDED AS
YOU KNOW BY THE CURRENT THE CFPB
DEALERSHIP.
I WILL POINT OUT THAT THE EW ES
EXEMPTIONS AT PRESENT TIME STILL
REMAIN UNCHANGED.
THIS SHOWS THERE'S BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. FOR THE CONTINUE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF RESPONSIBLE EW ES
ALTERNATIVES FOR CONSUMERS.
THERE WERE A FEW FIRMS OFFERING
EW ES WHEN I FIRST LOOKING TO
THIS -- SPACE MORE THAN FIVE
YEARS AGO.
NOW IT HAS BECOME A BURGEONING
MARKET WAS VARIOUS BUSINESS
MODELS.
AS EW ES GAINS TRACTION MANY THE
GYM IN THE PUBLIC POLICY
QUESTIONS ARE BEING RAISED.
AND THE LACK OF REGULATION
CALIFORNIA INVITES ON SAVORY
PRACTICES.
DURING MY TENURE AT THE CFPB I
OVERSAW THE DELIBERATION OF MOST
IF NOT ALL OF THE POLICY
QUESTIONS THIS COMMITTEE MAY BE
WRESTLING WITH.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE MY
VIEWS TODAY.
THESE VIEWS ARE WHAT ARE OF MY
OWN THEY DO NOT REFLECT THOSE OF
MY FORMER AGENCY.
FIRST QUESTION IS.
IS IT UP TO A CREDIT.
WHETHER OR NOT YOU W. IS
CONSIDERED CREDIT IS IMPORTANT A
QUESTION DETERMINING HOW YOU W.
A. SHOULD BE PROPERLY REGULATED.
AND IN SHORT IN MY OPINION YOU
DON'T DO IS NOT CREDIT.
THE CORE PRINCIPLE OF EW ISN'T
IT REALLY REALLY VERY SIMPLE.
ONE SHOULD BE ABLE TO ACCESS HIS
OR HER OWN A CREW WAGES.
A PORTION OF THE MONEY THEY HAVE
ALREADY EARNS ON DEMAND AND THE
WITHOUT CREATING A DEBT
OBLIGATION.
THE BILL IS BASED ON THE CREW
WAGES THAT ARE YET TO BE PAID.
IF NO WAGES AREN'T NO ACCESS IS
GRANTED.
NO FUTURE WAGES AND TO THE
SPECULATIVE RISK ASSOCIATED WAS
TAPPING INTO THEM ARE IMPICATED.
THINGS THAT CONSUMERS PAY A
FIXED ONE TIME NONRECURRING FEE
TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS PHONES
BASED UPON OR CALCULATE THE PONG
A PORTION OF THE OUR CREW INCOME.
THERE IS NO DEBTS THERE'S NO
INTEREST CHARGE THERE'S NO
COLLATERAL OR SECURITY INTERESTS
TAKEN FROM THE EMPLOYEE CONSUMER
HOLDING PLAYER.
AFTER CAREFULLY SCRUTINIZING
EITHER UPDATE FOR ONE THE CFPB
DECISION TO EXEMPT YOU W. A.
FROM THE ABILITY TO REPAY
REQUIREMENTS.
IN THE FINAL PAY THE RULE.
SEND A VERY STRONG AND CLEAR
MESSAGE THAT THE EW ES IS NOT
CREDIT.
THE SECOND QUESTION IS REALLY
ABOUT.
DOES EITHER BE A PROVIDE A LOWER
COST ALTERNATIVE.
WHILE I PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT
MARKET FORCES REALLY IN
ULTIMATELY DETERMINE THE PRICES
AS AS PROVIDERS COMPETE.
I UNDERSTAND WHY STATES MY
WANTING STILL A PRICE CAP.
THIS BILL DOES EXACTLY THAT.
IN NO EVENT UNDER THIS BILL.
MAY THE TOTAL FEE CHARGED TO A
CONSUMER IN A SINGLE MONTH.
EXCEEDS A STRICT CAP OF FOURTEEN
DOLLARS.
SO THIS ESSENTIALLY TRANSLATES
TO A MAXIMUM OF SEVEN DOLLARS
PER BI WEEKLY OR BI MONTHLY PAY
PERIODS.
AND THE THREE DOLLARS AND FIFTY
CENTS FOR WEEKLY PAY PERIOD.
HOLIDAY BECAUSE O THE BETTER
TECHNOLOGIES AND TO THE VERY
NATURE OF THE EE THESE PROGRAMS
AT THE PRESENT TIME ARE FAR LESS
EXPENSIVE IN A FEW CAP UNDER THE
BILL.
AND THE FAR LESS EXPENSIVE THAN
PAYDAY LOANS LATE FEES OVERDRAFT
FEES.
I BELIEVE THE PRICE CAP PUT IN
THIS PLACE PUTTING PLACING SPELL
IS VERY REASONABLE AND CAL WORK
FOR MOST EW ES PROVIDERS.
LET ME JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO TO
SHARE WITH YOU -- A CASE STUDY
FOR P. ACTIVE [inaudible]
ALL [inaudible]
FASTER.
IN THE PICTURE PATTY WAS CASE
THE CUSTOMER TO ACCESS UP TO
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
OF HIS ARM -- WAGE UP TO THREE
TIMES PER PAY PERIOD. FOR SINGLE
FEE OF FIVE DOLLARS THIS
COMPARES TO A TYPICAL FORTY FIVE
DOLLAR CHARGE FOR A TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE DOLLARS HAD A LONG.
SO AS YOU CAN SEE.
THE PRICE POINTS THERE'S NO
COMPARISON.
pFURTHER A GUARD RAILS TO AVOID
THAT TRAPS IT ALLOWS CONSUMERS
TO CHOOSE TO ACCESS EW ES UP TO
THREE TIMES IN A PAY PERIOD.
NOT TO EXCEED 50% OF THE CREW
AGES.
THE THIRD QUESTION IS IS REALLY
ABOUT DOES IT UP THEY PROVIDE A
LESS RISKY ALTERNATIVE.
SO I WILL I WOULD ARGUE THE BILL
IS FAR LESS RISKY AND IF YOU
STRUCTURE WELL -- YOU CAN
PROVIDE A MUCH BETTER AND SAFER
ALTERNATIVE.
AND THIS BILL REQUIRED TO GET UP
A NOT TO HAVE RECORDS I THINK
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT POINT I
WANT TO MAKE HERE -- I AND I
BELIEVE IN IN THE CURRENT -- AT
PRESENT MOST OF THE W. PROGRAMS
IN THE MARKET TODAY DON'T HAVE
RECOURSE SO IF FULL IF FOR
WHATEVER REASON OR FOR NO REASON
AT ALL.
THE CONSUMER DECIDES NOT TO
REIMBURSABLE PROVIDER THE
CONSUMER IS HELD COMPLETELY
HARMLESS AS A PROVIDER HAS NO
RECOURSE AGAINST CONSUMERS.
THE WORST CASE THAT HAPPENS THE
CONSUMER IS THE LAW ALSO FUTURE
ACCESS WITHOUT DELAY.
THE LAST POINT OUT TO MAKE A IS
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE CONSUMERS
NOT TO BE COMPELLED. TO
ESTABLISH A ACCOUNTS WAS A
PROVIDER AS A PRECONDITION TO
RECEIVE IT ON THE THIS IF CARD
THIS SAFEGUARD IT MIRRORS THE
COMPULSORY USE CALL PROVISION
UNDER REGULATION E. IS WHICH IS
A FEDERAL REGULATION -- ENFORCED
BY THE CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION BUREAU.
THIS PROVISION BASICALLY ENSURES
THAT CONSUMERS ARE NOT TO BE
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF BY A RULED
PROVIDERS THEY OF THE HANDS
OFFER OF ACTING EXPENSE EITHER
OBVIOUSLY WHILE CHARGING CARD
FEES OR OTHER PRODUCTS.
LAST DAY.
ALTHOUGH THE NATURE IN THE TERMS
OF THE W. PROGRAMS ARE FAR
SIMPLER AND EASILY
UNDERSTANDABLE FROM FOR
CONSUMERS WHEN COMPARED WITH
OTHER CREDIT TRANSACTIONS.
AS WITH ANY FINANCIAL PRODUCT WE
NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB
EDUCATING CONSUMERS ON HOW TO
RESPONSIBLY USE IT ON THE WAY.
MANY PROVIDERS TODAY ALREADY
OFFER FINANCIAL WELLNESS
PROGRAMS INCLUDING MAKING
FINANCIAL LITERACY AND THE
FINANCIAL COUNSELING AVAILABLE
TO CONSUMERS.
IN ADDITION TO FIND OF A
COUNSELING FOR EXAMPLE P. ACTIVE
OFFERS BUDGETING AND THE SAVINGS
TOOLS.
THESE BENEFITS THESE BENEFITS
ARE WELL COVERED IN THE FIVE
DOLLAR FEE AND COME AT NO
ADDITIONAL COST TO THE CONSUMER.
FINALLY THIS BILL PROVIDES A
VERY POWERFUL IN FORCING THE
MECHANISM AS IT CONTAINS A
PRIVATE Y. ACTION TO ENSURE THAT
YOU W. PROVIDERS OF HERE TO THE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND COMPLY
WAS REQUIRES SAFEGUARDS.
I WOULD LIKE TO AGAIN THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU.
YOU. TOO HAVE TESTIMONY AS WELL
I DON'T LIKE THIS IT TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS OKAY THANK YOU --
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SIGNATURE BRADFORD MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL
BUT WE JUST WANTED TO CONVEY OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE CONCEPT IN THE
PROGRAM.
FROM WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT IT IT
SEEMS LIKE IT IS VERY MUCH AND
MORE RESPONSIBLE LESS RISKY
ALTERNATIVE TO PAYDAY LENDING
BUT REALLY SHE'S EXTREMELY
COMPLICATED SO WE'RE JUST.
CONTINUING TO ANALYZE THE BILL
TO MAKE SURE THERE AREN'T ANY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OR
ANYTHING BUT JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
CONCEPT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU DISCOVERED LOWER THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE WE ALSO DON'T HAVE A
SUPPORT POSITION OR ANY POSITION --
BUT JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE THE
SPONSORS AND THE AUTHORS HAVE
REACHED OUT VERY EARLY ON AND
OFFERED TO WORK WITH US AND
WE'RE EAGERLY ANALYZING THE BILL
THIS IS A NEW AREA OF LAW.
SO -- AND AND THE ATTORNEYS --
NATIONALLY ARE PRETTY BUSY WITH
THE ATTACKS ON CONSUMER RIGHTS
AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL AND SO
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO CATCH UP --
BUT BUT DO BELIEVE THAT HAVING --
SOME PARAMETERS ON THIS TYPE OF
SERVICE -- WOULD BE REALLY
HELPFUL AND ESPECIALLY IF IT CAN
ENCOURAGE CONSUMER EDUCATION
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE THAT
TOO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
TURN MEMBER SUSAN MARTIN DOUBLE
CONSUMER PRESS ALSO REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD TODAY WE DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE A FORMAL POSITION
WE'RE ALSO WORKING THROUGH.
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
ALWAYS CLARITY AND PROTECTIONS
FOR THESE KINDS OF FINANCIAL
TRANSACTIONS BUT REALLY PREFER
THE DIALOGUE WILL CONTINUE.
THANK YOU.
I GOT A SET UP ON THE CENTER FOR
RESPONSIBLE LENDING ALSO --
THANK YOU FOR ENGAGING US AND
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
ON THIS THANK YOU.
GREAT ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
TEEN HEARING NINE ONTO THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR ALSO.
YES THANK YOU SENATOR COLORADO
FOR OF PRESENTING THIS BILL --
IT SURE.
FEELS BETTER THAN STARTING AT
THE TOP WITH.
CALGENE OF POOR PEOPLE WHEN THEY
NEED -- YOU KNOW A LITTLE BIT OF
MONEY TO GET THROUGH.
IT'S MUCH EASIER I THINK TO DEAL
WITH THAT THEN STUDY WHERE.
YOU KNOW THE INTEREST IS THREE
OR 4100% -- SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE -- YOU BRING THIS
FORWARD IN THIS WAY.
I ALSO APPRECIATE THAT -- YOU
DOING IN ADVANCE BEFORE SO.
THE MARKET GETS SO.
IN CHILE SO BIG THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO GO BACK AND REDO WHAT
HAS YOU KNOW BECOMES THE
PRACTICE SO.
DOING IN ADVANCE I THINK IS
GREAT -- I KNOW YOU MENTIONED
THE US SENATOR THAT.
YOU INTEND TO KEEP MEETING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND CONSUMER GROUPS
AND THAT'S ANOTHER BIG PLUS I
UNDERSTAND THEY BROUGHT THAT.
HAVE RESULT HERE TODAY SO THE
FACT THAT YOU BROUGHT IT UP
EARLY IT IS ALSO SOMETHING GOOD
I JUST HAVE A QUICK QUESTION IS --
IN ALL OF THIS CAN YOU REMIND ME.
WHAT'S THE MAX OR IS THERE A MAX
AMOUNT OF MONEY.
FROM THAT COULD BE.
BORROWED I KNOW IT'S A CERTAIN
AMOUNT RELATED TO WAGES BUT
REMIND ME AGAIN WHAT THAT IS.
YES IT'S 50% OF THE EARNED.
WAGES WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN EARNED
WHAT ALREADY BEEN AREN'T THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY SO IT'S NOT A
DOLLAR AMOUNT NO IT PERCENT
INJECTED BASED ON WHAT THEY WHAT
THAT IS CORRECT OKAY.
GOD ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
AS STATED -- THIS IS A NEW.
PRODUCT -- IT'S ONE THAT --
SEEMS TO HAVE GREAT POTENTIAL
I'M JUST HAVE SOME QUESTIONS AS
TO HOW LONG HAS THIS PRODUCT
BEEN ON THE MARKET AND HOW ARE
YOU ADVERTISING BECAUSE UP UNTIL
THIS MEASURES COME BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE I WAS TOLD OF A
FAMILIAR WITH.
THIS VERSUS SOME OF THE OTHER
PRODUCTS ARE OUT THERE THAT WE
ALL KNOW ABOUT AND WE ALL HAVE.
CONCERNS ABOUT.
CAN SOMEONE.
I CAN ANSWER THAT -- MY NAME IS
JOBS AND I AM THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER FOR BE ACTIVE
SO Vì HAVE BEEN IN BUSINESS.
OPERATING BUSINESS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN BUT AT A
VERY SMALL SCALE.
BECAUSE AS A DISRUPTIVE PRODUCT
IN A NEW COMPANY TAKES TIME TO
SCALE BUT WE HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY
OPERATING SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN INCORPORATED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE BUT THE
PRODUCT HAS BEEN OUT SINCE.
THE BEGINNING OF TWO THOUSAND
AND FOURTEEN ARE YOU SO YOU CAN
DEAL WITH CONSUMER DIRECTLY OR
THE BUSINESS DIRECTLY AS WELL.
CHAU HOW DOES THAT WORK GET OUT
HOW DO YOU HOW DOES CONSUMERS
FIND OUT OF IT AT PRESENT BE
ACTED ONLY DOES.
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS WITH UNITED
CONSUMER DIRECT SOLUTION.
AND WE BASICALLYGO TO THE
EMPLOYERS AND PROMOTE THIS AS A
FINANCIAL WELLNESS BENEFIT. TO
THE CONTRACT WITH THE EMPLOYERS
FIRST AND THEN THE EMPLOYER
PROMOTES THIS WITHIN THEIR WORK
FORCE.
AS A FINANCIAL VINCE BENEFIT SO
YOU ONLY CAN SPEAK TO PAY ACTIVE
BUT FOR THOSE THAT DO NOT TO
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS OUR
CONSUMERS LEARNING ABOUT THIS
PRODUCT.
THE WALL A TO DO IS JUST THROUGH
THE WORD OF MOUTH FACEBOOK
SOCIAL MEDIA TUTORS -- APPS
[inaudible]
FOR OKAY [inaudible]
AND HOW MANY ARE ACTIVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW -- S. USERS
OR EMPLOYERS -- IT AND ENTITIES
LIKE YOURS OR ENTITIES LIKE US I
BELIEVE THERE THREE THREE AND
NATION WANT.
A SIX SIX OKAY.
AND ALSO THERE'S A A A U. K.
COMPANY THAT'S ALSO ENTERING THE
US MARKET I'M SORRY AS A U. K.
US MARKET.
OKAY.
AND HOW ARE YOU CAPITALIZE.
OF THE ARE LIKE ANY MORE
SPECIFIC AMERICAN PIECE OF YOUR
CAP PLACE BY PRIVATE EQUITY.
AND VENTURE CAPITAL BASED OKAY --
AND SHOW YOU ALSO MENTION THAT
THERE IS FINANCIAL LITERACY OR
ASSISTANCE SO AGAIN.
IS THAT DIRECTLY WITH CONSUMERS
OUT SOMETHING THEY HAVE TO LOOK
AT ONLINE ON OUT AS ONE TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT AS FAR AS
FINANCIAL COUNSELING IS
CONCERNED WE HAVE ACTUAL
COUNSELORS.
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM ON A
VOLUNTEER BASIS THEY CAN CALL
AND SET UP APPOINTMENTS AND TALK
TO THEM AND FINANCIAL LITERACY
IS PART OF OUR APP.
SO ONCE YOU OPEN AN ACCOUNT ARE
THEY REALLY DID GET ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL LITERACY.
SO THERE'S NO THREAT OF BY A
PROBABLY IS THAT EACH -- A CAN
GET IN A CYCLE OF TAKING OUT
THESE LOANS I MEAN IS IT
SOMETHING THAT.
SOME ALARM THAT YOU HAVE THAT
SITS EIGHT YOU'VE TAKEN OUT SO
MANY AND WHAT ARE THE FOR THE
THOSE SAFEGUARDS WE HAVE A VERY
CONFIGURABLE RULES ENGINE THAT
ALLOWS YOU.
TO DISTRICT OF A LOST CITY THE
FREQUENCY THE AMOUNT THE
PERCENTAGES WE WORK WITH THE
EMPLOYERS IN A COLLABORATIVE
MANNER AND DIS DETERMINE WHAT
RESTRICTIONS THEY WANT TO IMPOSE
BECAUSE AGAIN B. R. A. B. TO B.
SOLUTION.
OF YOU DON'T DICTATE HOW THEY
SHOULD BE.
OFFERING THIS TO THEIR EMPLOYEES
IS A COLLABORATIVE EFFORT OKAY
SO IT'S A 50% OF INCOME -- THAT
IS MADE AVAILABLE TO THEM
TYPICALLY THEIR X. SIX THE
EMPLOYEES ALLOW ONE AXIS PER PAY
PERIOD OKAY.
IN ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ON WE
HAVE.
A OKAY HOW WOULD YOU MISTER WE
HAVE A RECOMMENDATION -- DO FAST
TO YOUR DISHES WHILE -- WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR DURAZO'S.
DO PASS AS AMENDED I SHOULD
STATE ARE SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
LIVELY DISCUSSION THIS IS A
PROJECT THAT IS -- NEW AND SO
THE BY AIR PRECIADO THE COMMENTS
AND AND THE THE INPUT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
EVERYBODY SO THAT -- PEOPLE FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH THE WITH THE
WITH THE WITH THE PROGRAM IF
THEY'VE GOT ANY OTHER --
SUGGESTIONS IN TERMS OF HOW TO
MAKE IT BETTER WE'RE HERE TO
LISTEN.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE BOTH THE INTEREST IN CONCEPT
THE TEAMS HAVE GREAT POTENTIAL
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT YOU WE DO
CONTINUE TO DIALOGUE INTO NOW WE
CAN.
SO SO MY INTEREST FRANKLY IS
PERSONAL IT IT'S YOU KNOW I HAVE
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT USE --
HIGHER INTEREST PRODUCTS -- AS A
WAY TO GET THEMSELF THROUGH THE
MONTH AND IT IT DOESN'T MATTER
HOW MUCH I'VE INTERVENE TO TRY
TO GET THEM TO USE DIFFERENT.
THE DIFFERENT MODELS IT'S WHAT
THEY FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH SO I
THINK IF THERE'S A A GOOD
ALTERNATIVE THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
YOU USE THEIR OWN INCOME.
AS PART OF THAT MODEL AYE I JUST
THINK IT'S GREAT AND SO I REALLY
AM EXCITED ABOUT THIS IN.
SHEET THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
TODAY THANK YOU SO WE HAVE A
MOTION BAR VICE YOUR SENATOR
CHIANG IS TWO THOUSAND A MINUTE
TO JUDICIARY -- MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE JUDICIARY SENATOR
BRADFORD HI.
I CHIANG.
CHING I GOT A I DON'T AYE.
AYE DURAZO.
YOUR AS A I WAS SO.
WITH SO I MORALE.
I PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO I THE MEASURE US
SEVEN VOTES WILL LIBERAL OPEN
FOR THOSE APPS A MEMBERSHIP
WHICH MEASURES UP THANK YOU.
CAN REACH US MONEY THANK YOU.
THAT'S A PRISONER HUESO
[inaudible]
THE YOU HAVE SB.
FOUR EIGHTY TWO WHEN I READY
SENATOR MEN -- AGAIN -- VERY
CONSISTENTLY EVERY YEAR I WORK
ON ACCESS TO CAPITAL BILLS --
OFTEN TIMES -- I'M ALSO WORKING
ANOTHER BILL HELPS PEOPLE
ESTABLISH CREDIT -- BUT OFTEN
TIMES YOU KNOW I'M I'M ALSO
LEARNING THAT -- A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE LOW INCOME RIGHT NOW ARE ARE
GETTING THEIR CREDIT DIDN'T BY
GOING TO THE HOSPITAL.
AND NOT PAYING A BIT LATE
PAYMENTS ON HOSPITALS ARE
RUINING PEOPLE'S CREDIT I MEAN
THERE'S A SOMEBODY'S WORK FOR US
SO MUCH WORK FOR US TO DO HERE
ON BEHALF.
OF THE PEOPLE OF OUR STATE.
THIS BILL IN PARTICULAR -- SIX
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL STATUTORY
PROTECTIONS FOR LOANS MADE UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA FINANCING LAW.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL SEEKS TO
ENACT SEVERAL CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS UNDER THIS THAT LAW
THAT.
ARE CREATE HIGHER STANDARDS TO
SAFEGUARD CONSUMERS WHO USE
SMALL DOLLAR LENDING PRODUCTS --
WITH THE WHAT WHAT IS HIS BILL
DO IT ELIMINATES THE FEES
CHARGED FOR LOAN MODIFICATIONS.
IT HAS -- THIRTY GET RESOLUTION
REQUIREMENT BEFORE LOS CAN BE
SENT TO COLLECTIONS -- WHICH
REQUIRES PEOPLE TO WORK WITH
THAT WITH -- THE THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WHO ARE HAVING A HARD TIME
REPAYING LOANS.
IT IT ELIMINATES EARLY.
PAYMENT.
OUR REPAYMENT PENALTIES WHY ARE
YOU PROVIDING A PENALTY FOR
SOMEBODY'S PAYING OFF THE LOAN
DOES MAKE ANY SENSE THAT
SHOULDN'T BE.
ALLOWED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT ALSO -- ENHANCES
REQUIREMENTS FOR ABILITY. TO
REPAY -- WILL WHEN ISSUE IN LOAN.
THAT **** HAS OUR THREE DAY
RIGHT TO RESCIND IF YOU GET A
LOAN CHANGE YOUR MIND YOU CAN
RESCIND THAT LOAN WITHIN THREE
DAYS.
IT ALSO REQUIRES A NOTIFICATION
TO CONSUMERS OF THE AVAILABILITY
OF ALTERNATE PRODUCTS IF THEY'RE
AVAILABLE IN THE COMMUNITY -- SO
PEOPLE KNOW THAT THERE ARE OTHER
OPTIONS.
IT ALSO ENHANCES REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE SPEC TO THE SALE.
OF ANCILLARY.
PRODUCTS SO -- AND ON ONE MORE
THING IN THERE ALSO -- PROVIDES
A COMMITMENT -- TO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL LITERACY IN THE
COMMUNITY -- ON BEHALF OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS -- ALL OUT I'VE
MORE COMMENTS TO MAKE BUT ALL OF
A KIND OF A SHORT MY COMMENTS --
SITE IF THERE ANY QUESTIONS I'D
RATHER RATHER.
I ENGAGE WITH -- MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE -- DIRECTLY AND WE
ALSO HAVE -- WITNESS HERE TODAY
JULIE CUT AT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE HISPANIC CHAMBERS.
OF COMMERCE IS HERE TO TALK
ABOUT.
WHY WE NEED THIS BILL?
THANK YOU SENATOR MISTER
CHAIRMAN JOINT COMMITTEE
CALIFORNIA'S BACK CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE -- YOU KNOW WHAT WE
SUPPORT THE BILL BECAUSE IT
PROVIDES ACCESS TO CAPITAL.
AND AND PROVIDE FOR SOME NEEDED --
CONSUMER -- PROTECTIONS --
ADDITIONALLY -- BY IMPLEMENTING --
CLEAR CONSUMER SAFEGUARDS
INCLUDING STRENGTHENING THE BILL
YOU TO REPAY STANDARDS. TO
ENSURE CONSUMERS PAY BACK.
PAY BACK THEIR LOANS NEW
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE CONSUMERS
ARE INFORMED ABOUT LOW COST
POWERING OPTIONS IN ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY TO PAY BACK THEIR
LOANS.
EARLY OR RESCHEDULE THEIR LOAN
PAYMENTS.
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT THE
LENDERS TO OPERATE.
IN THE STATE IN CALIFORNIA DO SO
TRANSPARENTLY AND IN A WAY THAT
HELPS BOWERS GET BACK ON THEIR
FEET.
I'M.
WE ALSO FEEL THAT -- WHEN
COMPANIES ARE TRANSPARENT WITH
THE REQUIREMENTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE GIVEN PRODUCT OR SERVICE
OFFERING?
AND STATE LICENSE NON -- PRIME
LETTERS ABOUT ABIDE BY STRICT
RULES ON THIS FRONT THE
CONSUMERS SHOULD HAVE THE
FREEDOM TO CHOOSE THE PRODUCT.
THAT IS RIGHT FOR THEM SO AGAIN
THIS IS.
WHAT WE'VE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
YEAR IN AND YEAR OUT MAKING SURE
THAT THERE IS ACCESS TO CAPITAL --
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR BUSINESS
TO BEGIN AND CONSUMERS TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THOSE IN AND BE
ABLE TO TRUST A MAN.
AND WE PAY BACK THOSE LOANS SLOW
THANK YOU.
AND TO SHOW WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MR MEMBERS AS ARE THE OTHER
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
DO HAVE -- LATE LETTER OF
SUPPORT AND WHEN I THANK THE
AUTHOR TRYING TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES PARTICULAR IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY IT'S
CYCLICAL THERE'S A LOT OF BOOM
AND BUST AND A LOT OFTENTIMES
WHEN IT'S AN EMERGENCY.
OUR MEMBERS ARE ALREADY LIVING
PAYCHECK TO CHECK PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK AND SO SOMETIMES THESE
PRODUCTS ARE WHERE THE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE EMERGENCY
ISSUES THAT THEY MAY.
BE EXPERIENCING SO WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AN ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SHE KNOWN WHAT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME [inaudible]
FOR SEE HERE [inaudible] TWO SIX
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS GONNA SEE
A LOT BONTA DHEAS AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA POLICY
FOR THE CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE
LENDING HERE IN OPPOSITION.
SEVERAL IS A NONPROFIT RESEARCH
AND ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO PROTECTING
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN FAMILY WEALTH
BY FIGHTING PREDATORY LENDING
PRACTICES OUR SISTER
ORGANIZATION THE SELF HELP
FEDERAL CREDIT UNION WE HAVE
NINETEEN BRANCHES AROSS THE
STATE.
INCLUDING THE FARM WORKER CREDIT
UNION THAT WAS STARTED BY MISTER
LET US WORK ON SAYS ARE CHAVEZ
OUR CREDIT UNION PROVIDES SMALL
DOLLAR LOANS -- FOR DOCTOR LOANS
CREDIT BUILDER LOANS MORTGAGES
FOR BORROWERS WITH UNTRADITIONAL
CREDIT.
US THROUGH OUR RESEARCH AND OUR
DIRECT SERVICES WHERE WELL
CONNECTED TO THE ISSUES ON THE
GROUND WE HEAR FIRSTHAND FROM
FAMILIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AND IT IS CLEAR THAT THE
SITUATION IS DIRE BECAUSE
LENDERS CURRENTLY HAVE THE GREEN
LIGHT TO AGGRESSIVELY MARKET
LOANS WITH UNLIMITED INTEREST
RATES TO CONSUMERS WE'RE SEEING
FAMILIES TRAPPED IN LOANS THAT
KERRY APR AS OF MORE THAN A 100%.
ONE OUT OF THREE BORROWERS WITH
HIGH COST LOANS END UP IN THE
FALL THEY'RE OFTEN SUIT FOR WAGE
GARNISHMENT AND MANY END UP IN
BANKRUPTCY.
LAST YEAR MORE THAN TWENTY
THOUSAND BORROWERS WITH CAR
TITLE LOANS HAD THEIR CARS
REPOSSESSED.
A FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR LOAN THAT
BALLOONS INTO 400-004-0000
DOLLARS IN SEVEN YEARS SHOULD BE
E. LEGAL.
IN FACT HELLO MIKE THIS IS
ILLEGAL IN THIRTY SEVEN STATES
BECAUSE OF STATE INTEREST RATE
CAPS OF 36% OR LESS -- DURING
THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX CONGRESS PASSED THE
MILITARY LENDING ACT THAT
PROHIBITS LOANS OF MORE THAN 36%
FOR ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY.
CALIFORNIA'S BEHIND AN SB FOUR
EIGHTY TWO DOES NOT SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
SB FORTY TWO WOULD ALLOW
PREDATORY LENDERS TO DO BUSINESS
AS USUAL SPECIFICALLY THE
UNDERWRITING STANDARDS ARE WEAK
AND DO NOT ENSURE THAT BORROWERS
ARE PROTECTED FROM ON AFFORDABLE
LOANS.
SB FORTY TWO DOES NOT PREVENT A
LENDER FOR MAKING A LOAN EAT
WHICH EQUALED OR EVEN EXCEEDED
THE AMOUNT OF A BORROWER'S
AVAILABLE INCOME IN A GIVEN
REPAYMENT PERIOD -- IN ADDITION
SB FORTY TWO DOES NOT PROHIBIT A
LENDER FROM EXTENDING A LOAN OF
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO FIFTEEN
YEARS WHILE THIS MAY BRING DOWN
A MONTHLY PAYMENT IT WILL COST
THOUSANDS MORE IN INTEREST IN
FACT PREDATORY LENDERS ARE DOING
THAT THIS NOW.
SB FORTY TWO WOULD DIRECT
LENDERS TO DISCLOSE TO CONSUMERS
THE FACT THAT THESE ARE HIGH
COST LOANS BUT THE UTILITY OF
SUCH DISCLOSURES IS UNCERTAIN AT
BEST WE'VE HEARD FIRST HAND FROM
BORROWERS HAVE NOT GOTTEN
DISCLOSURES -- IN BEFORE THE
FUNDS WERE DISPERSED INTO THEIR
BANK ACCOUNT WHICH IS ILLEGAL.
WE'VE HEARD THAT THEY HAVE NOT
GOTTEN THE LEAD -- DOCUMENTS IN
THEIR LANGUAGE WHICH IS ALSO.
THAT'S A REQUIREMENT BY
CALIFORNIA LAW -- DISCLOSURE IN
TEN POINTFONT IS NOT ENOUGH
WHAT WE NEED IS AN INTEREST RATE
CAPS AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
TURN MEMBERS IN MARTIN TELL US
IN YOUR POLICY COUNCIL WITH
CONSUMER REPORTS FORMALLY
CONSUMERS UNION I'M ALSO IN
OPPOSITION YOU SURE THE
PERSPECTIVE OF MY COLLEAGUE --
YOU KNOW THE THE LEGISLATURE IS
RAP IS GRAPPLING WITH WHAT TO DO.
ABOUT -- A HETEROGENEOUS
CONSUMER LENDING MARKET WHERE
MANY ACTORS ARE [inaudible]
TRANSPONDERS SAYING -- BUT ONE
SEGMENT CONTINUES TO CHARGE
INCREDIBLY HIGH INTEREST IT'S
THAT TIME AGAIN.
HAVE TO HAVE SHOWN TO PUT PEOPLE
IN A POSITION WHERE THEY ARE
WORSE OFF THAN BEFORE THEY BEGAN.
AND IN FACT THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT HAS RECOGNIZED
THAT AND LAST YEAR THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT ISSUED
A RULING -- IN THE CASH CALL WE
DON'T DILATORY CASE AND SAID
COURTS CAN FIND THAT IN THE LOAN
WITH INTEREST RATES ABOVE 90%
I'M COULD BE UNCONSCIONABLE AND
THEREFORE VOID AS A MATTER OF
CONTRACT LAW.
THAT'S THE COURT OPENING THE
DOOR FOR POTENTIAL INCREASED
LITIGATION OFFER JUDGE MADE LAW
AS TO WHAT'S A FAIR PRICE THE
LOOK IT DOES SO IN OUR VIEW THE
COURT HAS RAISED A QUESTION AND
THE LEGISLATURE MUST ANSWER IT.
WHAT IS A FAIR PRICE FOR A
CONSUMER INSTALLMENT LOAN ABOVE
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
CALIFORNIA?
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT IS THE
ISSUE THAT SQUARELY BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR AND THAT
THAT IS THE ISSUE AND THE
PRICING THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS
AND SO UNFORTUNATELY WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL.
IS AN APPROPRIATE SOLUTION TO
WHAT IS A VERY CLEAR VERY REAL
SYSTEMIC PROBLEM THAT WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH ANYONE
I'M HERE IN THE BUILDING TO
ADDRESS SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MONEY ADDITION WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SCOTT
GOVERNOR BEHALF CALIFORNIA
FINANCIAL SERVICES ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED.
RESEARCHER REMEMBERS THE PASSED
WITH CARTER WHICH ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY AND COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO ALSO OPPOSED THE
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED.
TESTING OF OUR LOW WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
DANIEL KESSLER BECAUSE OUR
BEHALF OF THE CALL CALIFORNIA
LOW INCOME CONSUMER COALITION IN
OPPOSITION.
ONLY SAN LUIS ON BEHALF OF ANY
THOSE US NATION'S LARGEST LATINO
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS
STRONG OPPOSITION.
CHRIS RESPONSE WHICH OF THE
COLLEGE REMAINING RIGHTS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION.
COMING WITH THE LA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN OPPOSITION.
HI RYAN FLANAGAN ON BEHALF OF
ONE MARK FINANCIAL SERVICES IN
OPPOSITION.
THE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ANY COMMENT
FROM OUR COMMITTEE SENATOR ALSO.
SENATOR WAS.
UP -- I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS.
IN THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS.
THERE WAS -- REFERENCE TO OF A
PILOT PROGRAM.
THAT GOES UNTIL JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND IF I
UNDERSTAND THIS RIGHT.
THERE WAS THERE'S A GRAPH THERE
I THINK IT'S A PAGE.
FOUR OF THAT COMPARES THE PILOT
PROGRAM WITH THIS BILL AND
COMMENTS.
AS TO THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THE PILOT PROGRAM AND THE BILL --
AND THERE ARE.
THERE ARE TWO AREAS IN WHICH THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE IDENTICAL SO IT
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING.
TO IMPROVE.
OF THE PILOT PROGRAM.
THERE'S ACTUALLY TWO AREAS WERE
SAYS A PILOT PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS ARE MORE.
RIGOROUS WHICH I TAKE TO MEAN
GOOD ON THE SIDE OF THE CONSUMER --
AND THEN THERE'S ONE WHERE IT
SAYS IT'S BASICALLY AYE
IDENTICAL TO THE PILOT PROGRAM
SO.
IT ALMOST FEELS LIKE -- THIS IS
WORSE THAN THE OR OR NOT DOING
ANY BETTER IN SOME CASES WORSE
THAN.
THE PILOT PROGRAM SO.
WHY?
WHY GO IN THAT DIRECTION RIGHT
WELL WE'RE TRYING TO IMPROVE --
AND PROTECT THE CONSUMER WHY GO
IN THAT DIRECTION INSTEAD OF
STRENGTHENING THE PROTECTIONS AS
AT FROM THE POINT OF VIEW OF THE
PILOT PROGRAM I JUST WANNA.
MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT AMEND THE PILOT
PROGRAM.
THE PILOT PROGRAM IN THIS BILL
ARE TWO SEPARATE THINGS.
THE COMPARISON WITH THE PILOT
PROGRAM JUST SAYING WITHIN ONE
SPECIFIC CAR PILOT PROGRAM THAT
SET TO SUNSET.
THERE THEY ARE THESE OTHER
COMPARISONS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WELL IT CAN BE
FAIR IN THE SENSE THAT THESE --
PROVISIONS ARE BEINGTESTED
CURRENTLY UNDER THE PILOT
PROGRAM BUT THE PILOT PROGRAM IS
A VERY DIFFERENT PROGRAM THAN
THIS PROGRAM.
THE PILOT PROGRAM DOES NOT.
COVER ALL THE PEOPLE THAT.
LENDING COVERS IN GENERAL.
PILOT PROGRAMS VERY SPECIFIC SO
I WANT TO KIND OF ADD.
OF A 100% PEOPLE -- TO LOOKING
FOR LOANS PILOT PROGRAM OWNS
ONLY COVERS A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THAT.
WE CAN START WITH A CONVENTIONAL
BANK ABOUT CONVENTIONAL BANK
GIVES LOANS TO ONLY IF YOU'RE A
BUSINESS IF YOU'RE AN INDIVIDUAL.
LESS THAN TH -- UP ABOUT 10% OF
OF THE BUSINESSES THAT ACTUALLY
LOOK FOR A LOAN FROM A BANK
ACTUALLY GET THEM THAT'S ONLY
10% THAT LEAVES OUT 90% OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
LONG WE CAN GET IT. FOR A A FOR
PEOPLE TO LESS THAN THAT.
SO A LOT OF PEOPLE IN OUR STATE
OUR OWN BANKED.
OR HAVE NO CREDIT OR HAVE A VERY
VERY BAD CREDIT.
AND AND AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAPPENS IN A IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE USE THAT.
INTEREST RATE LIMITS IS THAT YOU
BASICALLY MAKE AN ENTIRE -- A
VERY LARGE PERCENTAGE OF YOUR
POPULATION THAT HAS NO ACCESS TO
ANY KIND OF CREDIT.
IF THEY HAVE VERY POOR CREDIT
AND THEY ARE HAVE BEEN
COMPLETELY OMITTED FROM.
THE THE LENDING MARKET HOW DO
YOU RE ESTABLISH CREDIT HOW DO
YOU GET ACCESS TO CAPITAL IF YOU
HAVE A STATE.
THAT DOES NOT ALLOW THERE TO BE
SOME KIND OF LENDER THAT ALLOWS
THAT.
SO FIRST SOME INDIVIDUALS THEIR
pTHAT THESE INDIVIDUALS NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO CREDIT.
AND TO HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH
INTEREST RATE CREDIT. FOR THAT
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT DO HAVE
ACCESS TO HIGH INTEREST CREDIT A
LOT OF THEM REPAY THOSE LOANS
AND AND ARE GIVEN -- ARE ARE ARE
ABLE TO REESTABLISH CREDIT. FOR
THE ONES THAT ARE NOT.
WHAT USED TO HAPPEN BEFORE IS
PEOPLE WOULD GO TO THE BLACK
MARKET FOR CREDIT?
AND AND THEN WE'RE HERE STOCK AS
LEGISLATORS.
IN THE POSITION OF DECIDING.
WHAT DO I PREFERRED THAT WE WE
HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE DEFAULTING
ON THOSE ARE PEOPLE THEY'RE
GETTING THEIR KNEES BROKEN
BECAUSE THEY THEY?
ARE NOT PAYING THEM.
AND AND THOSE ARE REAL
SITUATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN --
THAT HAVE EXISTED IN OUR
COMMUNITY BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO THE BLACK MARKET FOR
LOANS.
OUT OF DESPERATION AND WHAT WHAT
WHAT CAN WE DO TO RESPOND TO
THAT.
WE CAN WE CAN WHAT WITHOUT
CUTTING ACCESS TO TO LOANS YEAH
WE NEED TO EDUCATE.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHICH THIS
BILL DOES ABOUT ACCESSING HIGH
INTEREST RATES WE HAVE TO CREATE
ALTERNATIVE PROGRAMS WHICH THE
PILOT PROGRAMS BUT IT
UNDERSTANDING THAT THOSE
PROGRAMS.
DO NOT HELP THE PEOPLE.
THAT ARE.
GET ACCESS TO CREDIT SO HOW DO
WE HELP THE PEOPLE THAT
CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
CREDIT OR DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
PROGRAMS.
THAT PROVIDE THEM CREDIT UNDER
THIRTY SIX OR UNDER FORTY UNDER
FIFTY OR UNDER 30% OR UNDER 20%.
HOW DO WE HELP THEM?
AND AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE
HELP THEM BY ELIMINATING ALL
SOURCES TO CREDIT.
BUT THERE ARE THINGS THAT WE CAN
DO I MEAN I'M I'M I'M TRYING TO
CREATE A BUILT.
THAT CREATES A STATE BANK I'M
TRYING -- TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
LITERACY I'M TRYING -- TO FIND
WAYS TO HELP I HAVE A A BILL
THAT ALSO HELPS PEOPLE WHEN THEY
OF WHEN THEY ARE PAY THE RENT.
IF THE RENT PAY THE RENT ON THE
CHIMNEY BASIS HELP SOME
ESTABLISH CREDIT.
THEY'RE ALL THESE THINGS THAT WE
CAN DO TO HELP PEOPLE TO STAFF
LEVELS SELFLESS CREDIT IF YOU
GET A IF YOU GO TO A HOSPITAL.
AND THERE'S A BILL FOR FOR
THIRTY FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
YOU CAN'T PAY IT RUINS YOUR
CREDIT.
I THINK THAT IN THIS STATE WE
CANNOT.
HELP PEOPLE THAT HAVE ACCESS BUT
THAT WERE MAKING.
MORE PEOPLE OUT OF PEOPLE THAT.
COME ACROSS SOME FINANCIAL OF A
OF SOME HEALTH PROBLEM AND WE'RE
STILL NOT LEGISLATING THAT.
IN ITS ITS BUT WHAT WE KNOW WHEN
I'M TALKING TO PEOPLE TO PROVIDE
THEIR OWN THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
THEY SAY.
AMONG PEOPLE THEY'RE SEEKING
LOANS ARE PEOPLE THAT CANNOT PAY
THEIR THEIR THE BILL.
AT A HOSPITAL.
AND AND THOSE ARE PROBLEMS WE
pLEGISLATURE UNTIL WE DO THAT IN
MANY CASES.
SOME OF THESE LOANS AND YOU KNOW
I'VE BEEN THERE I'VE I'VE I'VE
I'VE.
I'VE HAD TO YOU KNOW PURSUE.
LOANS OUTSIDE OF THE
CONVENTIONAL MARKET BECAUSE THEY
WEREN'T AVAILABLE.
A TO ME AND BACK THEN WHEN I WAS
MUCH YOUNGER AND LOOKING -- TO
YOU KNOW START MY BUSINESS
[inaudible]
AND FOR MANY PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
START THEIR BUSINESS AND AND
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING THESE
LINES OF CEDIT ARE ESSENTIAL
EVEN IF THEY'RE HIGH INTEREST IF
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
YOU CAN YOU CAN START A BUSINESS
AND YOU CAN HAVE SUCCESS AND DO
ALL PEOPLE FALL IN THAT CATEGORY
NO BUT I DON'T WANT.
TO FINISH THE PEOPLE.
THAT CAN SUCCEED.
BY TRYING TO SAVE THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE ARE FALLING VICTIM TO
THE SO WHAT WE CAN DO.
WE CAN DO NOT I'M I'M SEEKING TO
DO IS.
LOOK.
THERE ARE ALL THESE PROTECTIONS
THAT WE CAN HELP PEOPLE WITH IN
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS.
THAT WILL.
KEEP ACCESS TO CREDIT AVAILABLE
TO THEM BUT STILL EDUCATE THEM
AND LET HIM KNOW LOOK THIS OTHER
OPTIONS AVAILABLE.
IF FOR SOME REASON -- THEY THEY
WERE THEY WERE OF MISLED OR NOT
PROVIDED THIS INFORMATION THERE
ARE MANY WAYS FOR US.
TO ENFORCE THE LAW AND TO HELP
THEM GET OUT OF THESE LOANS AND
TO HELP THEM PROVIDE A ADVOCACY
BECAUSE THAT ALSO COMES THROUGH --
THE VARIOUS GROUPS THAT WORK
WITH WITH NON.
WITH.
ATTORNEYS THAT HELP PEOPLE IN
BANKRUPTCY -- THEY KNOW THE LAWN
AND AND KNOW THAT THEY CAN.
HELP THESE INDIVIDUALS BUT EVEN
WHEN I TALK TO A BANKRUPTCY
ATTORNEYS ASSN WHAT'S THE NUMBER
ONE REASON THE PEOPLE GO INTO
BANKRUPTCY [inaudible]
MORTGAGE LOANS.
AND THESE ARE LOW INTEREST RATE
LOANS BUT FOR VERY HIGH AMOUNTS.
AND THOSE ARE A BIGGER PROBLEM
TO OUR SOCIETY THAN THESE HIGH
INTERET RATE LOANS.
OF IN TERMS OF BECAUSE IN
BANKRUPTCY SO.
IT MIGHT MIKE.
MY BILL MAKES IT HARDER. FOR
THESE LENDERS TO REPOSSESS
VEHICLES IT GIVES.
PEOPLE THAT WERE -- THAT MADE A
DECISION OVER A MOMENTS -- YOU
KNOW -- OTHER BY I MEAN HOW CAN
ANY OF THESE GROUPS THAT
ADVOCATE FOR CONSUMERS COME COME
HERE TO THIS FORUM AND SAY I'M
OPPOSED. TO A LIST OF CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS.
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY'RE OPPOSED
TO WHAT THE BILL DOESN'T DO.
AND THAT'S LET LET'S I I I THINK
HERE I THINK THE THE WHAT THEY'D
LIKE TO SEE IS A CAP ON INTEREST
RATE LOS WE HAVE ANOTHER BILL
THAT DOES THAT.
AND AND THIS BILL DOES NOT
CONFLICT WITH THAT.
ONE AND SO DO YOU CAN APPROVE
THIS BILL IF YOU LIKE THE OTHER
BILL THAT PROPOSES A CAP YOU CAN
YOU CAN GO FOR THAT ONE AS WELL
BUT THESE ARE NOT.
BILLS A CONFLICT WITH EACH OTHER.
BUT IT IS IT'S UP TO YOU FOR FOR
MY TASTE.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO TO HELP.
PEOPLE THAT CAN ACCESS ACCESS TO
CHEAPER CREDIT INCLUDING
SUPPORTING PROGRAMS BUT LET'S BE
HONEST.
PROVIDING ACCESS TO CAPITAL IS
VERY EXPENSIVE AND FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT DO IT IT'S VERY
RISKY.
AND THEY'RE NOT GONNA DO IT IF
IF THEY'RE GOING TO BE PROVIDING --
RISKY LOANS. TO A OF A CROSS
SECTION OF THE COMMUNITY THAT
CAN AFFORD TO REPAY THEM OR HAS
A LIKELY THAT THEY WON'T REPAY
THEM IS JUST NOT GOING TO HAPPEN
AND IT'S A AND THAT THAT PROGRAM.
WHAT DO YOU LIKE IT OR NOT?
IT'S GOING TO DRY UP OF FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT.
WHETHER THEY HAVE A ROOF ABILITY
REPAIR OR OR PEPPER NOT IT
DOESN'T MATTER BECAUSE IT WILL
NOT EXIST.
AND FOR THE PEOPLE THAT IT DID
IT IS CURRENTLY SERVING
SUCCESSFULLY.
THEY WON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
SO WHERE WILL THEY GO WHERE WE
SEND THEM.
WELL THANK THE COURT HAD CENTER --
I WAS JUSTASKING ABOUT THE
COMPARISON BETWEEN THE TWO BUT
SINCE YOU RAISE THE ISSUE OF THE
PERCENTAGE OF YOU KNOW ONON
LOANS -- THAT BOTHERS ME EVEN
MORE THAT WORRIES ME EVEN MORE.
I BEEN AROUND FOR COMMUNITIES
AND WORKING CLASS COMMUNITIES MY
ENTIRE LIFE.
AND THE THE PROBLEM I THINK HERE
IF IF THIS IS.
AS CONNECTED AS YOU EAT YOU SAID
WHICH WAS NOT MY QUESTION.
BUT YOU'RE SAYING THIS BASICALLY
LEADS TO WE NEED COMPANIES.
WHO CAN LOAN MONEY TO POOR
PEOPLE AND IT ALMOST DOESN'T
MATTER WHAT THEY CHARGE THEM?
I DON'T THINK BECAUSE SOMEONE IS
POOR.
THAT A COMPANY SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO GOUGE THEM AND CHARGE
WHATEVER THEY WANT.
WE WOULDN'T DO THAT IN A
HOSPITAL SAID SOMEBODY GOES TO
THE HOSPITAL WE WOULD NOT ALLOW.
THAT HOSPITAL TO CHARGE.
WHATEVER THAT WHATEVER WHATEVER
THEY WHEN IT'S HAPPENING NOW.
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW WORST STOP
WHEN WE HAVE SOME THINGS IN
PLACE -- WE HAVE SOME THINGS IN
PLACE HI BU YOU KNOW THE THE
DOESN'T MEAN BECAUSE SOMEBODY IS
POOR THE YOU GONNA TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THEM.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S TAKING PLACE
IS COMPLETE ADVANTAGE OF POOR
PEOPLE ALREADY POOR AND WE'RE
GOING TO WORSEN THE CYCLE OF
POVERTY SO I I GUESS I'M ONLY
RESPONDING WITH THAT BECAUSE YOU
YOU MADE A CASE FOR IT.
I WAS SIMPLY TRYING TO SAY THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE BILL AND
THE PILOT PROGRAM DIDN'T APPEAR
TO HAVE.
YOU KNOW OF ANYTHING THAT WAS
BETTER -- AND THAT'S WHAT I WAS
ASKING -- FOR AND LSO ARE THERE
ANY CONSUMER GROUPS THAT.
YOU'RE WORKINGWITH THAT YOURS
THAT ARE WORKING WITH YOU TO SAY.
WE NOT A FIX THIS IS A GOOD
THING OR IT'S NOT.
YOU KNOW I'M IF WE'RE IF IT'S A
CONSUMER PROTECTION WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CONSUMER GROUPS THAT
ARE SUPPORTIVE AGAIN IT'S UP TO
YOU TO DECIDE IF THIS IS A
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
I THESE ARE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
I'VE.
I'VE RECEIVED A 100%.
OF WITH CONSUMER FEDS SINCE I'VE
BEEN HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE THE
THESE ARE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
BUT AGAIN THE CONCERN AS WELL
HE'S NOT ELIMINATE HE'S NOT
CREATE A CAP.
ON THE INTEREST RATE IN THIS
BILL AND THAT'S A DIFFERENT
THING AGAIN.
IF WE SEPARATE THAT IS THIS A
CONSUMER PROTECTION BILL
ABSOLUTELY I MEAN.
ANYBODY COULD SEE THAT THIS IS
IMPOSING REQUIREMENTS TO PROTECT
THE CONSUMER I'VE LISTED WHAT
THEY ARE.
AND THERE ARE WONDERFUL
PROTECTIONS BUT AGAIN I ALSO
WANT TO CLARIFY LOOK.
THEY THEY SHOULD BE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BECAUSE IT IS CONSUMER
PROTECTION IT'S MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION DOES IT PROVIDED
EVERYTHING THEY WANT TO SEE IT
DOESN'T BECAUSE I I I AGAIN I
BELIEVE.
LOOK.
I KNOW POOR PEOPLE.
LOW INTEREST RATE LOANS.
THIS IS NOT HAPPENING TO PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY'RE POOR AND I JUST
WANT TO CREATE THE DISTINCTION
THAT'S HAPPENING TO THEM BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE CREDIT WHERE
THEY HAVE VERY BAD CREDIT OR
HAVE THEY HAVE A HISTORY.
OF NOT PAYING BACK LOANS OR
DEFAULTING ON LOANS FOR HAVE
BANKRUPTCIES OR WHATEVER.
THE THE THE THE CONDITIONS THAT
THEY HAVE LIT LEAD THAT AS
CREATE CRAZE SITUATION WHERE
THEY DON'T HAVE HAVE ACCESS TO
CAPITAL.
THANK YOU YOU CAN BE A RICH
PERSON AND HAVE JUST COMPLETELY.
HERBAL CREDIT AND AND NOT BE
ABLE TO GET A LOAN I MEAN.
OR HAVE BEEN A RICH PERSON.
SO THERE'S A DISTINCTION I I
HAVE.
VERY LOW WAGE WORKERS THATOWN A
HOME WITH A LOW INTEREST RATE IN
MY DISTRICT AND THOSE ARE THOSE
ARE NOT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
AFFECTED BY THIS AND AGAIN.
THEY'RE NOT THE ONES THAT ARE
THAT NEED.
A HIGHER INTEREST RATE LOANS
BECAUSE THIS IS -- BUT THIS
AGAIN GETS CHOOSE BERRIES
[inaudible]
US US.
DEFINED SET OF LIEU OF OF LOANS
THAT ARE OUT THERE IS GOING TO
CREATE.
NEW SAFEGUARDS IN A FEW SUPPORT
THOSE NEW SAFEGUARDS ARE
PROPOSING.
IF YOU THINK THEY'RE NOT ENOUGH
WELL.
I'M SORRY I DIDN'T DO ENOUGH.
BUT IF IN THESE PARTICULAR IF WE
COULD PUT HIM IN STATUTE.
THOSE CONSUMERS I WOULD BE IN A
BETTER POSITION.
TODAY ABOUT THE WITH THIS BILL
THEM WHERE THEY ARE TODAY.
IN ADDITION COMMENT -- CENTER IN
YOUR PRESENTATION YOU STATED
THAT THERE WERE ANCILLARY --
OPTIONS FOR CONSUMERS I DON'T
SEE THAT IN THEIR WORTH THIS
PROVIDES THAT INFORMATION.
TO CONSUMERS OF OTHER PRODUCTS
THAT WERE AVAILABLE AND GET IN A
A STATEMENT HERE THAT WE WERE
AMENDED THAT OUT BUT I DON'T
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE MAKING
REFERENCE TO BECAUSE IT'S NO
LONGER IN THE BILL SO.
YOU YOU MAY IT IS A STATEMENT
THAT YOU MADE THAT.
YOU PROVIDED ACCESS TO ANCILLARY
OTHER PRODUCTS AND NO THE THE
PILOT PROGRAM IS WHAT I WAS
REFERRING.
TO BECAUSE THE POPE PILOT
PROGRAM WAS CREATED HERE BY
STATUTE.
AND THIS IS A BIT -- AND I'M
JUST ONLY.
MAKING REFERENCE TO THIS PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WAS. FOR MAKING
ROOM I'M I DON'T THINK THAT'S
WHAT YOU STATED IN YOUR
STATEMENT YOU SAID.
OF ALL THE SAFEGUARDS ONE WAS
THAT YOU MAY NEED ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION OF ANCILLARY OTHER
PRODUCTS AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS
BUT I DON'T KNOW NO I DID NOT
SAY THAT I THINK YOU -- WHAT I
SAID WAS THAT THERE IS?
AN ON OKAY.
IT'S BEEN AMENDED UP SORRY I DID
MAKE A STATEMENT YOU'RE RIGHT
SOUL KEY EIGHT EIGHT I JUST SIX
CAN WE AMEND THAT BACK IN AND
AND ONE WHAT PREVENTS US FROM
PUTTING THOSE SAME SAFEGUARDS IN
THAT THE PILOT PROGRAM MASS.
I'D HAVE TO KNOW WHAT I WAS MY
STAFF PREPARED THIS SO I'M VERY
SORRY.
THERE WAS SOME SOME CONCERN
CONCERNS RAISED AT THE OUTSET
THAT MAY BE CONFUSING TO
CONSUMERS SO WE HAD INITIALLY
MENTORED OUT IN AS IT WAS
INTRODUCED IT DID INCLUDE THOSE
PROVISIONS.
AND WHETHER THOSE WERE
BENEFICIAL OR NOT WAS IN
QUESTION SO WE'VE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS WITH YOUR GRACIOUS
STAFF HERE TO CLARIFY THAT THAT
CLARIFY THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL.
SO ARE YOU WILLING TO TAKE THOSE
AMENDMENTS THAT KIND OF LIKE PUT
TO SAFEGUARD CHEN THAT THE PILOT
PROGRAM AS AND PROVIDE THOSE I
MEAN WE TO INITIALLY PROPOSED
SOME FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND THIS
CAME FROM YOUR OFFICE OF TO I
GUESS MY CONCERN IS. TO PROVIDE
THOSE SAME TO SAFEGUARD SET UP
EITHER PROGRAM HOUSE AND IF
YOU'RE WILLING TO DO THAT WE
DESIGNED THE BILL SO I HAVE THE
SAME BECAUSE SENATOR ALSO RAISE
SOME GOOD.
POINTS ON THERE IT'S AND IT'S
REALLY CONCERN BUT ALSO WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THESE PRODUCTS
EXIST BASED ON WHAT YOU SAID A
LOT OF HARD WORKING PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO TRADITIONAL --
BANKING INSTITUTIONS IT'S OVER
THREE MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ON BANK WE
AREN'T WE CLEARLY UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT I THINK WE SHOULDN'T BE
LESSENING THOSE SAFEGUARDS AND
AND AND SAFETY NET FOR CONSUMERS
SO I WOULD YOU MAKE UP YOUR MIND-THE START.
I'M WHAT YOU WELL I AM I I'M I'M
GOING TO ASK THAT YOU TAKE THE
MOMENTS THAT AFFECTS -- MIRROR
OF WHAT WE HAVE IN A PILOT
PROGRAM AND GOING FORWARD YOU
FOR WILLING TO DO THAT GOT IT
YOU'LL HAVE A MOTION -- IT WOULD
MEAN YOU EVER COULD CENTER
PORTANTINO.
THE BILL IS GOING TO APPROACH
THE AXE RIGHT.
JUDICIAL CARRY GONNA SAY IF YOU
WANTED TO GET ME THOSE
AMENDMENTS.
I WORK WITH APPROACH THAT BUT
IT'S GONNA JUDAS FIRST SO THAT'S
FINE SOLIS SOONER YOU WILLING TO
TAKE THOSE AMENDMENTS AND
JUDICIARY WERE IN MY BILL
ORIGINALLY SO OF COURSE I AM.
RIGHT.
SO WERE LOOKING AT A AT LOOKING
FOR MOTION -- WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT SENATOR WAY
SOUL WE'VE TAKEN THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND JUDICIARY -- TO
DO PASSED THANK YOU -- WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR CAFIERO WILL
YOU PLEASE MADAM SECRETARY
CALLED WORLD.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN IN
JUDICIARY SENATOR BRADFORD HI.
I CHIANG.
AVAIL COMMANDO I DORADO.
HUESO I WAS SO AYE MORALE
[inaudible]
NO PORTANTINO [inaudible]
PORTANTINO I FIVE YES. FOR YES.
THE MEASURE HAS FOUR YESES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR THOSE
ABSENT MEMBERS WHO ARE AS
EVERYBODY HERE OTHER THAN
SEARCHING.
YEAH SHE'S SHE'S GONE FOR THE
DAY SO IS EVERYBODY HERE
[inaudible] FOR YES WE'RE GONNA
OPEN UP TO ROLL ON ALL THOSE --
FOR THOSE ABSENT MEMBERS SO.
MA'AM SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL
THE ROLL ON THOSE -- MOST IMAGES
OF BIN FASTER WE'RE MISSING.
VOTES ON CALENDARS. TWO FIFTY
ONE AND SB. FOUR FIFTY FIVE ZERO
LONG CONCERNED. ZERO CATCH YOUR
CONSENT.
I PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I THAT'S
SEVEN CONSENT.
MEASURE OUT.
SEVEN ZERO SENATE BILL FOUR
EIGHTY TWO MOTION IS TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY.
OR WITH AMENDMENTS TO DID YOU
SHERRY SENATOR CHIANG
[inaudible]
SENATOR MORALE.
HE VOTED NO.
NO NOT A SORRY YEAH HE'S VERY
VOTED ON THAT.
POLICIES ARE COMING UP.
PORTANTINO.
I GUESS.
SENATE BILL.
FOR NINETY SIX WELL -- I'M SORRY
DO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO BE
TAKEN INTO TO SHERRY SENATOR
MORALE.
MORALE I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
PORTANTINO I SEVEN MEASURES OUT.
SEVEN ZERO THE CLOSER GEN.
AND ITEM SIX WAS REMOVED FROM
THE AGENDA SO -- THAT CONCLUDES
THE BUSINESS.
OF THIS HEARING BANKING AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS.
WE STAND ADJOURNED